[Musik]
sechs uhr morgens viele stunden arbeit
liegen vor lastenträger viele hundert
kilo wird er am ende des tages getragen
haben
endlose treppen hoch und runter die
bambus stange sein einziges hilfsmittel
sie gibt seinem beruf den namen bank ich
arbeite so acht neun stunden jeden tag
bis zu 60 euro kann ich verdiene sein
arbeitsplatz chongqing dass sich selbst
die größte stadt der welt nennt in ihrem
verwaltungs gebiet leben mehr als 34
millionen menschen die stadt wuchs
schnell in die berge hinein das
markenzeichen von chongqing das ständige
auf und ab
deshalb braucht es beim bands wie lüd
deutschen textilien schuhe lebensmittel
trägt er durch die unzugänglichen
straßenschluchten 40 kilo hat er diesmal
auf der schulter wenn eine seite
schwerer wird dann muss ich das gewicht
mit der schulter ausgleichen die schicht
von lodz und startet am hafen
dort kommen die kreuzfahrtschiffe an die
chinas reich gewordene mittelschicht mit
ihrem vielen gepäck an spülen viele
wollen es nicht selbst tragen
der marsch beginnt
er beeilt sich denn er braucht etwa vier
touren pro schiff um auf sein geld zu
kommen wie ihn gibt es noch rund 10.000
bonbons die preise stehen fest ich
bekomme einen euro 30 für jedes
gepäckstück 66 ist liu die schon seit 30
jahren verdient er mit seinem körper
geld er hat keine schulausbildung die
stadt gibt ihm nur diese chance ich muss
eine pause da oben machen
der rücken schmerzt der atem geht schwer
[Musik]
wir hatten nur 9 euro vereinbart
aber der alte mann hat sich so gequält
deshalb habe ich ihm etwas mehr gezahlt
am monatsende kommt er auf rund 900 euro
viel geld für einen vom lande
luccin will uns später zeigen wo er
aufgewachsen ist
vorher fahren wir in einen reichen
viertel von chongqing hier leben die die
es geschafft haben wie leo ii
sie war einst verkäuferin nun wohnt sie
mit ihrer familie in einem luxuriösen
haus in 20 jahren hat sie sich
hochgearbeitet heute ist sie an drei
restaurants und an einem hotel beteiligt
die einrichtung hat sie selbst entworfen
normalerweise nimmt man einen
innenarchitekten aber ich wollte das
nicht
ich habe hier das haus gestaltet wie ich
es haben wollte
sie hat zwei kinder beide sollen im
ausland studieren lieber in europa denn
amerika mag sie nicht
ihre eltern waren bauern sie ist
millionär in china und sie sind reich
geworden kann das jeder schaffen
nein das ist nicht so einfach
du brauchst glück und du musst die viel
mühe geben mein mann und ich haben viele
opfer gebracht
der aufstieg war leidvoll schon ging
boomt der aufstieg des landes wirkt
offiziell so schmerzfrei chinas
kommunismus funktioniert nach den
gesetzen des kapitalismus wer nicht
mithalten kann der muss bei steigenden
mieten wegziehen nur vorsichtig trauen
sich das einige anzusprechen
manche lebten hier seit generationen
dass sie gehen mussten bricht ihm das
herz realität zu ihren restaurants jeden
tag kontrolliert sie ob alles läuft die
konkurrenz in der gastronomie ist groß
deshalb hat sie angst um ihren erfolg es
gibt so viele leute die geld haben wir
sind nicht superreich wenn ich aufhöre
hart zu arbeiten dann werde ich schnell
aussortiert
lucio kehrt einmal im jahr in sein dorf
zurück generationen vor ihm lebten auf
dem land eher gingen die stadt wie so
viele hundert millionen von
wanderarbeitern ein wenig wohlstand hat
er sich ertragen
meine hauswände waren vor jahren noch
aus altem leben dann hatte ich genug
geld gespart und habe ein haus aus stein
gebaut
in zwei jahren will er hier mit seiner
frau seinen lebensabend verbringen sein
sohn wird nicht mehr als bergmann
arbeiten müssen user schön hat ihm ein
studium bezahlt er arbeitet in einem
büro ich bin sehr zufrieden dass hinten
hat sich gelohnt auch wenn ich sehr müde
wenn wir nicht glücklich
es gibt dieses alte sprichwort das
größte glück ist ein sohn aufzuziehen
der auf die universität gehen kann
nach zerstreut chongqing wie eine
kristallkugel es wirkt wie eine
märchenstadt in der träume wahr werden
sie glauben an den chinesischen traum
der sehr amerikanisch geprägt
in zehn jahren wird mein unternehmen
noch größer sein und ich noch
erfolgreicher
in einer kleinen kammer am fuße der
wolkenkratzer von chongqing lebt leo
darwin und seine kollegen
sie sind stolz auf ihre arbeit die
letzte generation bank schuftet für ein
besseres leben vor allem für ihre kinder
sie fühlen sich als ein kleiner teil der
erfolgsstory dieser stadt und chinas